solving a hard puzzle in a game can make
you feel like a genius but getting stuck
on one can frustrate you to the point of
throwing the controller and quitting the
game for good in the last decade we've
seen a number of puzzles and games that
have challenged our brains and even
brought the gaming community together to
figure them out here are four of the
most challenging puzzles in gaming
brought to you by America's Navy
the intricate puzzles in Fez required
serious dedication to solve but none
more so than the black monolith puzzle
if you're a completionist your mission
is to collect all the special cubes in
the game including three secret red
cubes to get the final red cube you need
to figure out the secret of the black
monolith you won't be able to find the
puzzle in your first playthrough beat
the game to unlock the ability to look
around in first person then once you're
in the right room you have to use your
new ability to stand on a blank Square
and input a specific code to activate
the monolith the problem it's impossible
to figure out on your own players in the
Fez community had to band together to
figure out the code and test every
single possibility once you put in the
code the mysterious floating block
appears and now you have to figure out
what to do with it
fezzes development team leaked clues
that another code had to be entered
somewhere else in the room it took the
Fez community over 66,000 tries to
figure it out so you have their tireless
work to think if you've got the time you
could try to crack the code yourself but
if not mindless walkthroughs was kind
enough to create a walkthrough video
with a code on screen red cubes for
everyone about halfway through
Dishonored 2 during the 6th mission you
find yourself in the dust district here
you will come across the jinn - Locke
which keeps you from getting into
stilton's Manor the jinn - Locke is a
combination lock that requires you to
match a set of names with a set of
symbols figuring out the combination of
the lock allows you to skip most of the
dust district mission so how do you do
it to the right on the door you will
find the jinn - riddle which spells out
the solution to the lock combination if
you're stumped by the riddle and you try
to look up the solution online you're
out of luck the riddle and its details
are randomized for each game so someone
else's solution will not work for you
tough break time to crack some codes
while it is possible to test out every
possible combination that would take a
really long time the jinn - riddle is a
logic grid puzzle that contains short
word problems game crate built one that
you can find on their site the trick is
to figure out the relationship between
the different elements mentioned within
the riddle and while figuring out the
solution may not really save you any
time overall you do get an achievement
for solving it called Eureka
portal brought us unique gameplay that
challenged our perspective and
problem-solving abilities figuring out
how to use the portals to traverse
through each level forces you to think
differently and really tests your
spatial awareness the hardest portal
test chamber by far is chamber 18 where
all the skills you have developed up
until that point are put to the test
YouTube user x12 ozx demonstrates how to
move through the chamber in this video
making it look easy and making me feel
really dumb carefully place your portals
to move up the levels in the chamber you
come across a door to the exit in order
to open it you need a cube to hold down
the button getting the cube involves
figuring out this mess of a room get
through the androids get across the room
get the cube and get back to the button
to hold it down but wait there's more as
if getting the cube wasn't hard enough
you have to quickly ascend platforms and
shoot portals in midair in order to get
to the top and finish the level
[Music]
last on our list is a puzzle game so
challenging that I quit halfway through
and never went back the witness is a 3d
puzzle game that involves exploring an
open world you progress by navigating
mazes and solving puzzles that each have
their own set of rules with clues
scattered around the island or within
the environment some puzzles have no
clues at all there are around 650
puzzles in the witness but fortunately
you don't have to solve all of them to
finish the game while the entire game
belongs on this list one section of
puzzles in particular is the most
difficult and mentally exhausting the
infamous challenge the challenge is an
optional set of puzzles located inside
the mountain it's a time-based challenge
that requires completing 14 randomized
puzzles within 7 minutes to solve the
puzzles you must draw on the rules you
have learned throughout the game it's
impossible to cheat off a walkthrough as
someone else's puzzles won't be the same
set you end up with as ps4 trophies
demonstrates here head deep into the
mountain to find the challenge solve
this pillar then make your way through
the area until you find the music box to
start the challenge music will start to
play if you have not solved all the
puzzles by the time the music stops you
will fail
if you screw up I need to start over the
puzzles are randomly generated and will
be different every time it's incredibly
stressful those are four of the most
challenging puzzles in gaming brought to
you by America's new
what do you think the hardest pozzolan
gaming is let me know in the comments
below and thanks for watching
[Music]